do you have any idea the storm you've
created your order would you get in
deliver the package like we were never
there we were compromised we have to
adapt you thought driving a tank over
half a Sarajevo was the answer yes sir I
did
do I look like a [ __ ] to you yes sir no
sir
no I work here has not been fully
accomplished
rumor has it during World War two Nazi
stole gold from the French that was
worth the fortune
townspeople flooded the village stop
now it's all at the bottom of the lake
what do you say boys oh you realize what
we're talking about here recovering more
than three hundred million dollars in
gold bars and nobody's seen in 50 years
we're talking about a major unauthorized
operation under 150 feet of water right
in the middle of enemy territory
there's a chance to do something
extraordinary for the people of this
country
hell yeah
we funk
it seems Serb headhunters are actively
searching to kill you you don't fight
nice yeah that's okay you do I
you realize you broke every oath you
took we said I'll go out with a bang
I probably should have one different on
the way there thanks permis I got one
behind us too
we're go first one boys ain't no
stopping
Thank You Jane
why are you laughing that's just I look
like a clown
it's the Colin I'm basically a crossing
guard you got my whistle my stop sign
come here give me a kiss